de acuerdo a su experiencia que tan
probable son estos riesgos que advierten
en esta carta
Hola Andrés Buenas noches Muchas gracias
por la invitación Bueno mira aquí el
detalle con la carta es que pone esta
moratoria de seis meses pensando en que
no existe un marco regulatorio robusto
en el que se puedan predecir Qué tipo de
riesgos puede puede llevar estos modelos
de Inteligencia artificial pero ojo que
aquí también una de las cuestiones es la
carrera por desarrollar nuevos modelos
que sean redituables entonces también es
eso que no sea el tema Bueno más bien
que el tema de de tener mayores
ganancias nos lleve a una carrera
desorbitada
Y es que precisamente son cada vez más
las empresas que están implementando
este tipo de tecnología sana se está
moviendo demasiado rápido estas
compañías tanto las que desarrollan la
Inteligencia artificial como las que la
implementan
Pues sí el justo el tema fue que la
explosión que causó el uso de chat gpt
hizo que compañías que se habían
detenido en sacar al público sus modelos
de Inteligencia artificial de tipo
chatti lo sacaran justo porque vieran
que justo porque vieron que la adopción
del público fue muy bien recibida
entonces aquí lo que está diciendo la
carta que fue por cierto a propósito de
una declaración que sacó el mes pasado
Open ella y que se acosambleman que es
su director ella Open Ella es la empresa
que desarrolló chatti Entonces en este
en esta carta dice vamos a llegar a un
punto en el que probablemente
necesitemos analizar Cuál será el el
momento en el que tengamos que ponerle
un límite al crecimiento de estos
modelos entonces en la carta que firman
elon musk Store Russell Steven snack
están diciendo ese punto es ahora y ya
han existido otros puntos en los que
anteriormente también se ha puesto un
freno a estos avances Pero esto es
principalmente porque están diciendo
Bueno estamos listos para que exista un
sistema que pueda ser eventualmente
más inteligente que el que los humanos
en el caso que se desarrollara un
sistema de Inteligencia artificial
general o que pudiera ponernos que
pudiera dejarnos obsoletos